Islam is terrified of obey people
professing atheism alright again I think
that's I don't know what experience
you've had maybe with from reading
European history books but I said I
suppose you should read books from about
Mesopotamia and it's like if I may just
finish I'll let you respond so the
Prophet Mohammed has had a famous debate
with a Bedouin atheist right there was
no intolerance their debate did Betty
when a Turkish became Muslim but there
was no intolerance just because the guy
initially profess to be atheist um Abu
Hanifa famous classical scholar in
medieval Iraq Baghdad actually had
public open-air debates with atheists
presumably there's atheists were living
in Baghdad all the time to actually be
invited to open-air debates and no one
killed them all was intolerant to them
at all whatsoever and when you say Oh
Islamist is terrified of atheists I just
want to say something you're not special
we encounter polytheists we encounter
Christian Tura Trinitarians we encounter
Zoroastrians for our history and from
our perspective you're all arguing
exactly the same thing which is somehow
the the finite thing is this is also
infinite eternal and we don't really we
don't really see you as different
actually you're just an just another
stage yeah it's not a flavor of ice
cream that we are basically encountering
so I don't don't make yourself out to be
what else more special than you are from
the our perspective and as for their
issue of tolerance of atheists I think
you should question your founders of
your very ideology which pervades the
West liberalism John Locke in his letter
on toleration argued that you should
tolerate different Christian sects are
Protestants typically but not yes
because you can't trust what they say
they don't believe in an a higher moral
value all of then mainly what is
expedient Rousseau made also the same
argument and some people say that under
the current you could say atheistic idea
as opposed to the natural rights
arguments of John look but the
Benthamite arguments of utilitarianism
really morality is only based on
expediency and then people's rights are
based on whether it's expedient to the
state to even tolerate your right so
that it's not related to debate itself
but the guy brought it up and it's
really dissing journey
to bring up in that kind of weight